what's up guys welcome back to another
hazel devlog i thought i'd do something
a little bit different here today
instead of just taking you into hazel
and explaining what i'm doing i thought
i would actually show you some of the
development process as well as talk
about
what exactly is going to be coming next
so yesterday i did a live stream twitter
tv slash the channel i typically stream
like at least once a week and we have
like the whole game engine series where
with all of the planning everything
happens live and that's like hazel 2d
but then also throughout the week i try
and stream myself like working on hazel
big hazel hazel 3d all that stuff that's
also where like the optimization october
kind of project orange ties into as well
and so yesterday i just had a nice chill
stream just talking about like what i
want to do with hazel and working on
hazel itself and i thought that you guys
might want to see like a little bit of
that so i've put it together into this
video so this devlog is going to be
basically taken from yesterday's stream
we're still kind of working on the mesh
workflow thing that i mentioned in the
last devlog which will be linked up
there in case you missed it there are
also some very exciting things as always
coming very soon that i'm excited to
share with you guys but hey this is a
devlog so i'm saying that like at the
moment i'm just working on optimizing
the mesh workflow then i'll move on to
optimizing hazel itself in like the ways
that i talked about in the optimization
october video and then
uh it should be pretty fun from there
i'll just say that so yeah i hope you
guys enjoyed this slightly different
video if you like this by the way
this is uh still for sale there's a link
in the description below to buy some
merch my wife drew this turkey why a
turkey
well oh gee oh gee churno stream
watchers will know why i'll just leave
it at that don't forget you can also
support hazel and get access to hazel by
going to patreon.com huge thank you to
everyone who makes all of this possible
without further ado let's get right into
the stream so we have fractured cuban
orange coop and if i just drop in orange
cube
right
let's
so this guy is at zero zero zero
and that's what it looks like ah the
weird normal maps i forgot about that
actually
whatever um and then fractured cube so
fractured cube let's also bring that to
zero zero zero
um
[Music]
well first of all they don't actually
seem
oh this isn't a zero zero zero never
mind i lied let's put it at like zero
five zero just because zero zero zero is
in the ground and then we'll put this at
zero five zero as well
and you'll see that they are not they're
not they don't line up
they're not aligned and the reason
they're not aligned is because
like literally the geometry is not
aligned
they're different right um and i think i
don't know which one's correct if we
just make a normal cube and we put it at
zero five zero we'll easily see which
one is correct it looks like our boy is
correct i don't know why it's out boy
but basically this orange one is correct
right and then this one's wrong um
but
yeah like it's obviously not uh ideal
having this and that's also why
well
that's also why if we shoot this you
guys might notice that there's a bit of
a jitter because it just kind of
you know we spawn a new one in but it's
at the wrong position and whatever and
it's just kind of annoying
um that we have that so i want to fix
that up real quick shouldn't be too
difficult if we just uh go to i think it
is called fractured cube
and it's a mesh source
let's just let's just open our blender
uh and then we'll import
fbx i kind of want to import both of
them
we'll see
because my my problem is that i don't
necessarily know where
it's supposed to be right
because i'm just going to line the other
one up um
so let's import the other one well the
other one's just a normal kind of cube
but it's just nice to have it so here it
is this kind of orange boy this is where
i want to have it lined up actually is
lined up with the gridded cell so i
think what we should be able to do
is snap to absolute grid right
is that gonna work
well it works for this but i don't know
if it's gonna work for all of these
yeah see it's a bit
it's not actually doing absolute grid
snap is it
um
but that's okay actually we can just i
think we can just but i don't really
want to do that do i
i can zoom in and make it
ultra precise
look at that jump
okay that looks pretty good i doubt
anyone's gonna be able to tell a
difference so
whatevs
okay now we export ah because the
transforms
no never mind
yeah we do have to remake it because the
the transforms
when you make this the transforms get
put in here right
so that's why um
so
but it should be very easy to remake
well kind of that's a bit annoying
though but how will we deal with that
we'd have to update the transforms
right so would i how would i
i guess i would like to select all of
these and then be like update transforms
from mesh and so what that will do is
look up the mesh
and snap the transforms
back to what they should be
i guess that would be reasonable
okay so now what should happen is if i
click on one of these yeah i should have
the option so which one did i just click
on
cell08 if i
i can reset transform to mesh
a and see how it just snaps to this
so that's perfectly in position now
because i did the reset transform but if
i select the whole lot and i do reset
all transforms to mesh
they all reset look at that perfect
first try i mean it wasn't particularly
hard but you know
now this is just a model a very dense
model
i'll show you just how dense it is
well it's not that tense it's dense for
physics but it's
it's okay it's not that dense all right
brilliant and now i can do update prefab
and what this should mean is that now
these are all perfect
so much like updating and stuff i think
that's i mean it's hard to tell but
yeah that looks that looks flawless now
so now they should look better let me
just make these shadow settings not
terrible quickly
because well i don't know why but our
default
shadow settings are actually
like trying to look bad deliberately
almost
this should be better
so you can shoot these out of the sky
oh
um
hold your hold your horses
controller
so
what i should be able to do is just plug
this in because surprise we have this as
well
plug it in and then
i thought i added it on this computer oh
i'm not even focused there we go
i had i had um obs focused
this playing with a controller
pretty cool playing claw
let's go shoot some cubes
i'll play with my hands here so you guys
can see
ah i need an aim assist i'm done pretty
well without aim assist but
aim assist would be nice
so what do you guys think is it ready to
ship on steam yet
oh man
no i need some like particle effects and
decals and stuff
decals decals i know why
for a while i said decals is a bit of a
joke and i actually just say it on
ironically now
um if you you can also shoot it shoot
these pieces on the ground i'm just
holding down trigger
so
yeah and actually one more thing we can
do which is pretty cool i'll save this
i always don't know if control s works
there needs to be some feedback when you
save
um but i also maybe
i don't know if this works but i might
be able to run the runtime so that means
not the editor
so there's project orange uh
i don't know if this will will be
maximized i don't know what situation
this will be in
full screen is false i guess i could set
full screen to true
this will be maximized
now that doesn't work
ah that's because
i think um there's this yeah this is one
little thing
where
there's this one little thing that
doesn't work in
the runtime and it's just a little
little thing yeah see and then now
you're playing
real game let's make it full screen
though
i haven't actually tested full screen in
a while
whoa that does not work
wait
it looks fine for you guys
i think i've got like obs open here and
it's looks fine but i'm actually about a
third of the screen for me is flickering
black
like i can't see a third of the screen
but it looks fine on stream does it look
fine for you guys on stream because for
me in real life
it does not look fine i'll try and take
a photo okay let's go back to
false i'll just play a windowed
um but yeah so we got pretty much a game
now so my plan with this and what i want
to do what i really want to do over time
is i want to make like a little first
person shooter i don't know i've been
watching like call of duty videos
recently
there's this guy i forgot his name man
like art
i don't know he's been making like these
kind of video essays on why he's gone
through like all the call of duty games
and he's just saying like which ones are
good which ones are bad
and like i recently watched the modern
warfare two one and because one warfare
2 is like my favorite
first person shooter of all time
probably especially the multiplayer
um and
uh it just kind of like it's a bit
nostalgic you know and
i feel like what i really want to do is
make like kind of a
you know uh kind of multiplayer fps or
like even maybe split screen to begin
with because we don't have networking in
hazel yet and that will take a while to
put in but i'd love to introduce some
multiplayer stuff to hazel and maybe
make some kind of fps game that's fun to
play not as deep not like
not full-on like call of duty art style
obviously that will take like a huge
team but
something simple and fun you know that
will just be fun to play at a lan party
or whatever and then put that up on
steam probably for free and i think
that'll be sick
so
that's kind of my kind of longer term
plan
as i destroy all these cubes
and yeah it's going to time with this so
no i'm not sure i don't i don't think
it'll be like a multiplayer fps
deathmatch game i think it'll kind of be
the way that project orange is heading
at the moment because this is like the
start of it right so i think it'll just
be the way that project orange is
heading at the moment which is kind of
like
maybe some kind of like survival game so
maybe it'll be like a multiplayer fps
but it won't just be like about killing
everyone and then respawning and that's
it it'll kind of be mixed in with
survival somehow
and like you know kind of like maybe
weapons or whatever these things kind of
give you maybe some energy and then you
can use that to like shoot people and
shoot more of these things and
whatever like i think it'll be cool to
have some kind of
mechanic yeah
i want to make a game with halo you
should distribute a binary yeah that's
i'm planning to maybe do that
but um you can always just support on
patreon so like 10 bucks and then you
can get all the source code and if you
can build it yourself
um then you can you can make this
am i gonna switch to visual studio 2022
yeah i will eventually there's just no
real reason to do it yet like why
i'm pretty happy
with the current
situation anyway um
so yeah so that's kind of the state of
the state of things i want to basically
um
i'm glad that we added that we fixed
that cube thing and we added the kind of
reset transform and stuff like that
that's kind of nice
i should probably put that somewhere
else because as i create delete yeah
let's maybe put them in a different
place so create delete
and then
let's do
an i'm gui separator
and i don't know about the prefab thing
we'll see
so there we go it looks a bit a bit
neater now so if i right click on cube
spawn and create an empty entity does
that make it yeah it does make it a
child okay good
oh but this is a bit
does that not delete the
does that not update
and situated callback context destroy
entity
[Music]
exclude children
what's that oops what's the default
false so it shouldn't be excluding
children
uh yeah but this isn't um
this isn't removing the child from the
parents
so if i'm if i have a parent
that's a bit of a bug
the thing is like i don't know if i have
that much interest releasing hazel as
like a standalone binary thing because
like i mean you know unity unreal just
use those engines like if you want to
learn more about engines and so
therefore you want the source code and
you want to tweak them and all of that
stuff then you can support hazel on
patreon and get access to it that way
or if you want to just
if you're not interested in making games
if you want to play a game then
obviously hazel will be able to
distribute games that's kind of the
point the goal is ultimately to like
ship a game on steam
so um
yeah so let's add that
empty entity again and let's delete the
entity and yeah so we the arrow
disappears because
because it's um
doesn't have any children anymore and
it's aware of that okay fantastic so
yeah not sure like as far as where this
game goes not sure but again it's it
started off as just a way for us to
be able to visualize some stuff
some like performance issues definitely
hide the grid
um
visualize like some performance issues
and we'll not visualize but like
showcase we'll say some performance
issues oh there's actually a way you can
get up on this roof
if you um
just spam jump or hold jump or something
and i think you have to spam it like
yeah there we go
brilliant i kind of like that mechanic
though again like look at this look at
these shadows man that's not
i gotta
change the way we
deal with
shadows
to be a little bit nicer
by default or whatever
cube hunt kind of like duck hunts but
cubes so you can see i think the
performance is slightly dropping no
actually it's still 16.
it feels like it's dropping a bit maybe
because i'm streaming whatever yeah it
drops to 30 v-sync drops to 30 every now
and then and that's just going to get
worse and worse
because we're all rendering these kind
of individually
if we take a look at the draw calls
then you can see that each of them is
like an individual draw call
even though the geometry is like
identical and so we have like over a
thousand draw calls now and stuff like
that
so
yeah not ideal
um we also have a whole bunch of lights
but the lights i think are okay so this
is showing the light complexity
um and because they're pretty well
spread out i think it should be okay i
mean if we look at the
if we look at the
render statistics then
the actual geometry part like even on
the gpu we're only spending eight
milliseconds and the actual geometry
plus like is like four
four to five so
and that's with that that's without any
sorting and
tons of overdraw and we don't care about
that at all so
it's actually pretty decent
i think so it's probably not worth
optimizing
um like is in the light the light stuff
i think is pretty good
and each one of these cubes not like not
like actually each one
not each piece but each cube has one
light on it so that kind of glowing
orange piece that you see let me just
hide this
this glowing orange piece actually has a
point light attached to it
so that's why it's
showing up in the light complexity and
stuff
i guess like my ultimate concern here is
what about so static meshes should still
be fine
so we need to like this is almost ready
to be merged into master i think but i
really have to probably
uh
open
like
the actual
sandbox project which is in hazelnut
sandbox project sandbox so we'll open
the sandbox project and we have to make
sure that
that stuff still works because i don't
think it will
like this actually seems to be here
surprisingly but
oh it does work what
why does this work
i didn't know this worked
what
so how how
so these are all meshes with sub some
sub-mesh index zero i guess they could
be static meshes but they're just not
and that seems to be acceptable well
yeah i mean why wouldn't it be right
oh but what about something like sponsor
i don't think that will work so let's
try sponsor man i have an open sponsor
in so long
kind of scared
okay so it doesn't work uh that's okay
let's go to debug
that's actually probably just a bug
why does this work a lot well yeah i
just wasn't expecting it to work so you
know it's it's a real fear you know some
sometimes when something works even
though you think it shouldn't it's scary
because
it might be more broken than you think
so i'm always kind of just wary of that